hey man it's Kevin Smith and I'm Jason
Mewes and I've got some real exciting
news right our brand new movie Jay and
Silent Bob reboot is coming to theaters
nationwide for exclusive first look
screenings October 15th and the 17th
this is the sequel to the movie Jay and
Silent Bob strike back which we made in
2001 so it's akin is about 18 years to
get to the sequel man we're kind of lazy
but we did it and it's great we want you
to come see it with us click the link
below for more information and we'll see
you there reboots to the Nuge snoo games
please come see it man otherwise we
won't eat this year Wow wow this is
awesome man it's packed it's awesome I'm
usually not the one who comes out first
so this is very exciting for me I was
told that I get to come out first and
say hello to everybody man
the guy guys gonna come out and be more
articulate and tell you guys some
awesome things that are going to be
happening
I don't know I'm super excited about
this whole weekend man I've been coming
here since 97 and it gets bigger and
bigger and crazier and more fun and so
many cool things I know you guys I don't
know how many people were here
beforehand to see the the Marvel stuff
but I didn't want to say anything really
we're not here for the movie that you
think we're here for it's about me
and I'm about to tell you guys I'm in
this new Marvel movie it's called Muse
no that would be awesome now no really
though I'm so happy to be here and I'm
so excited that my buddy's coming out
you know we've known each other forever
this one I got to play around I like me
it was like a family affair my wife was
involved Kevin's daughter and so many
people and Kevin will again tell you way
better than I can but I'm excited he let
me come out first and introduce
cupboards
it's persuades me
[Applause]
we'll go this one man oh my god thank
you for being here ladies gentlemen
number one number two first off happy
Comicon everybody I look forward to this
moment all year long is the beginning of
my year man coming out here talking
everybody and stuff like that normally
we just sit around talk about cool [ __ ]
other people do this year I have
something cool to talk about myself
which is fun but before we do let's
address the elephant in the room is
[ __ ] tough to follow a Marvel panel
man Jesus it would be like following
Liam Neeson I imagine it's just like
that dude makes an impression and
[ __ ] I don't know that I could it's
kind of like Kevin Feige comes out here
and unfurls his dick and it just keeps
going the whole stage and then I come
out here and I'm like look at this and
they zoom in on it [ __ ] man Bob be
honest with you like everything they
said made me [ __ ] happy and I thought
it was so smart I think it's ingenious
and insidious that part of phase 4 is
like the Disney Plus stuff where it's
like they already had my money but I'm
like you want everyone else's money as
well oh my god I can't wait and it's so
weird they only showed this wasn't like
2 years worth of stuff
that's it I have so much to live for man
like
excellent to be here it's been a
wonderful year so far I was here on the
IMD boat interviewing people that has
been a lot of fun the good folks at
Legion them set up a handprint yes
Allegiant Legionnaires set up a
handprint ceremony for me and J at the
theater box right here in town which was
so incredibly special man when you stick
around for like 25 years people like you
can put your [ __ ] in that [ __ ] and so
felt like a real honor we got some stuff
to get to man and we'll get to it and
we're gonna jump into Q&A and talk until
they throw us off the stage we have a
trailer for this new movie we made
called Jay and Silent Bob reboot we put
the trailer on line like two days ago on
Thursday or something like that
early ahead of time because I knew that
I had other stuff to bring to the panel
and show people and stuff so I knew we'd
be able to show more things that were
only gonna be seen in this room and I
just wanted to get out ahead of the fray
because I knew a bunch of cool things
right I mean [ __ ] top gun to happen
didn't [ __ ] like that Tom [ __ ] Cruise
came to the con man
and he [ __ ] jumped up and down on the
stage that it's relic fantastic the dude
never [ __ ] ages and [ __ ] and the only
thing I don't understand is like he's
such a great actor but he seems to think
like will only go see his movies if he
almost dies now like now they showed him
in the trailer for Top Gun he's in the
[ __ ] jet and part of the cell of the
movie is like that's [ __ ] him flying
how do we get away with this give us $10
you know and they'll [ __ ] get it as
well so I wanted to get out in front of
the other trailers so we put it up for
folks to see but we've got some other
stuff to show but before we show you the
other stuff just in case there are
people that haven't seen it what not I'm
gonna show you that before I do that
Jason was just out here and then he
[ __ ] abandoned me it'd be nice if he
came back and he brought the other
member of the cast who make the
triumvirate of the top three characters
adjacent will you escort out my daughter
please ladies and gentlemen please
welcome playing Millie in our new movie
Jays daughter is my daughter Harlequins
Beth
so we're gonna show you the trailer and
then right after the trailer like when
it ends it's gonna go right into a scene
so we're not gonna come back out right
away let you enjoy the scene its pretty
long scene I think it's about five
minutes old yeah it is I cut it's five
minutes in line I cut it when tower
stone so it's catching up to me and [ __ ]
like that but how I remember I was
sitting there cutting it going five
minutes that's that's how it should be
exactly five minutes not a second more a
second less because I was really baked
I've been smoking this amazing [ __ ]
Weed Man if you're in California it's
called caviar gold that is [ __ ] the
best and oh my god I've smoked that and
I cut this clip for you because I went
through the whole movie I was like what
would they like best I really want to
showcase the kid because the story is
about them kind of like you know we've
been saying for like since we wanted to
make this movie you know this is how
I've sold it constantly I was like Jay
and Silent Bob strike back if you
remember is the story of Jay and Silent
Bob find out that Hollywood is making a
movie based on them so they go to
Hollywood to stop that movie from
happening and then I would say like but
that movie was like 20 years ago almost
man 18 years ago and I've grown as a
filmmaker since then and as a
storyteller so I wouldn't bother to make
that movie any movie I make now about
Jay and Silent Bob would be way more
advanced so Jay and Silent Bob reboot is
about Jay and Silent Bob finding out
that Hollywood's making a reboot of that
old movie about them and then they go
across the country to stop that movie
from happening all over again
so it's been an absolute delight to sell
the movie that way but also like
something of a deception as well because
that's part of it that's what got us
into it but if I made the exact same
movie which trust me at one point I
wanted to it originally the original
inception was let me see if I can get
away with it well my favorite things
ever happened in the movie biz Gus Van
Sant the great director Gus fun son he
made Good Will Hunting Good Will Hunting
got like nominated for a bunch of awards
and at that point Gus could do anything
he [ __ ] wanted right that's when
Hollywood comes knocking and they just
back up the money truck and they're like
oh my god you're the flavor of the month
everyone thinks you were genius what the
[ __ ] do you want to do and [ __ ] and Gus
picked they're like the weirdest thing
in the world you could pick he was like
I want to remake Alfred Hitchcock's
Psycho
and you know a lot of people were
outraged and [ __ ] the internet wasn't
what it was now but it broke the
internet even back then and [ __ ] like
that because people like you can it's
sacrosanct and Gus Van Sant's point was
like yeah but like kids won't watch this
movie anymore he goes it's a brilliant
[ __ ] movie but because it's black and
white nobody's gonna watch it right then
my heart broke cause I was like buddy
clerks but still he had a point he's
like kids won't watch his brilliant
movie but the Billings got old people
and he's like so I'm gonna take that
movie and remake it shot-for-shot he
wanted to take psycho remake it exactly
like Alfred Hitchcock made a
shot-for-shot and people got [ __ ]
pissed at him and [ __ ] like that he
still went and did it anyway I always
thought it was cool because I'm like
that's so weird and film school he like
he could have done anything he wanted
and he was like let's just see if we
could [ __ ] do this so I would never
do that with somebody else's working
[ __ ] but I would do it with my own so I
always liked that idea and I was like
I'd started a Jane ssambap reboot
started as the idea of like let me see
if I can you know make fun of reboots
while just doing the same movie again
and we did for like a draft and then it
changed because Jason Jason is a father
and has been one for four years got a
four-year-old daughter named Logan
and the weird thing is and maybe it's
not that weird but Jason is handsome
like the best father I've ever
encountered in my in all my days being
on this earth including my own dad
including the father I was Tarly she'll
tell you good dad not great right just
like your mother and but Jason on the
other hand a wonderful dad his
interactions with Logan I've gotten to
watch for four years he's incredible
with the kid he was born to be
somebody's dad like he interacts with a
kid and such an amazing amazing like at
her level I mean emotionally they're on
the same [ __ ] level anyway but like
man he's got this great relationship
with the kid and that started to inform
the movie I was like what if that was
the movie like Jason being a dad is a
weird wonderful thing to see in real
life like I wish he had been a dad
before I was a dad because I would have
learned from his example honestly
speaking like oh that's how you [ __ ]
do it and [ __ ] like that so I was like
what if that was the movie like Jay
turned out to be a dad and he actually
turned out to be like a good dad so it
started germinating that's where the
movie started kind of coming together
and whatnot in my head and meanwhile the
audience had a lot to do with it anyone
that follows me on Instagram and stuff
whenever I put up a picture of me and
the kid like you know kids got usually
long blonde hair or a long dish blonde
hair whenever I put up a picture of the
two of us in the comments section you
know people are like very sweet and [ __ ]
like oh that's cute father and daughter
and then a lot of people [ __ ] vast
majority of people say dude you better
get a blood test she looks like Jay and
so so the hunts been going on for like
years and it's it's in your head
[Applause]
really just bummed me out and it it sits
there and you're like oh maybe these two
things like should go together and stuff
the movie is won like it's not one
inside joke but it's one meta joke after
another after another and one of the
meta jokes to me was like oh [ __ ] like
what if I took the audience joke and
just been like yeah [ __ ] you're right
that's funny isn't it [ __ ] you know like
work smarter not harder and they came up
with a good idea so thank you for that
[Music]
so I started writing the script man and
it came together in a really like lovely
way so putting these two together like
on the screen there was certain magic to
it man the idea that like he knew her
since she was born
so there's moments where we get some
emotional stuff going in the movie and
whatnot and I don't think we could have
gotten it out of them because Jason like
gets real emotional I mean I swear to
you this is [ __ ] crazy to say but it
should be expected I'm 48 so expect Anna
and I'm a [ __ ] middle-aged stoner who
cries at everything so naturally the
movie's gonna have like way more heart
to it than anything I've done before so
in in this like there's a few moments in
the movie where they have these
interactions where I swear to you like
you if you know I'm not going to
everyone and you definitely will but it
gets crazy emotional you'll get choked
up and some people cry and then you'll
stop and go like this is a [ __ ] Jay
and Silent Bob movie man and that's like
what I'm interested at this point like
you know it's just like how Gus Van Sant
was like I just want to see if I can do
it like if you're coming to see a Jay
and Silent Bob movie like I know you're
there for the laughs and I think I can
deliver him to you but while you're
sitting there laughing like let me see
if I can give you something else all the
stuff I've ever done that people really
[ __ ] love just hit war it's heart on
its sleeve like [ __ ] people love
chasing Amy and ship because people that
Louie wears it's hard on sleep
so within us I was like I'm gonna go for
as funny as we can like we did the first
one but at the same time it's got to
matter
you know like Scott Mosier and my
longtime producer and my friend and
SModcast partner he wasn't involved with
the movie you know he was off making the
Grinch cartoon movie and [ __ ] and he
watched the flick when we were done and
he didn't know anything about it so I
was like which things first Buse q movie
i ever made without him and he goes you
know for the first like 15 20 minutes i
got what you were doing man you had a
joke that you wanted to tell and the
joke was i'm just gonna make the same
[ __ ] movie over again and [ __ ] like
that and you found a loose structure
upon which to place it and everything
was working great and I enjoyed it and
stuff but if that was the whole movie
you know at a certain point I would have
been felt felt like well that was a
waste of time he's gone but then all of
a sudden the real story kicked in and
he's like and that's when I became
engaged and really interested he's like
you took it in a different direction
he's like if people you know if the idea
of comedies you want to surprise people
and hit him with something and he's seen
before and arranged the words in a
certain way where it's gonna press the
funny bone or whatever and get a emitted
emotion out of them he's like you're
gonna do that as well emotionally you're
gonna get like people feels land and I
was like oh [ __ ] yes so that's what the
movie is and that's what Hartley's kind
of rolling it is but I don't have a
scene to show you know that's very
Harley centric that's also like
comic-con appropriate and [ __ ] so what I
went for was the scene you're about to
watch stars Jason Lee is the Great Brody
Bruce returns
and Brody is gonna set up the idea of
the movie for us bird it's the very
expository beginning of the movie and
Brody's gonna set up our mission so
you're gonna find out the plot and
everything like that but also Brody's
gonna break down pop culture current pop
culture so I take my character from 1995
who was obsessed with Marvel Comics and
met the actual Stan Lee of course in his
lifetime how would he react to the age
of Marvel movies bring a phase one two
and three and [ __ ] like that so we're
gonna get a taste of that so you're
gonna watch the trailer right after that
the scene with Brody's gonna kick in and
we're gonna come back out we're gonna
chitchat for a while so without further
ado ladies and gentlemen we worked real
hard on it I I got through the heart
attack because I wanted to desperately
make this movie and I made it thank you
and I made it with two of my favorite
people in the entire world my daughter
and my only son so we're really [ __ ]
proud of it man enjoy the trailer enjoy
this very first look anyone is anywhere
has ever seen of Jay and Silent Bob
reboot we made it for you here we go
[Applause]
so that's the setup for the movie from
that point forward the journey begins
we're off on the road and whatnot along
the way we encounter justice as you see
in the trailer Shannon Elizabeth from
Jay and Silent Bob strike back and
that's when we meet Millie and as you
saw on the trailer she joins the journey
and stuff we're headed toward chronicon
ladies and gentlemen and there's a
chronicon you know the whole third act
of the movie takes place at chronicon so
I've been walking around comic-con like
you know I normally yell out happy
comic-con everybody but because of the
movie I've constantly been shifted into
happy chronicon and people like what
he's hi and they're not [ __ ] wrong
but for the wrong reason and [ __ ] it's
because for the last few months of my
life we've been living in chronic con
and chronic con looks exactly like Comic
Con as you saw the logos are the same
and [ __ ] like that
once we get into the comic-con audience
there are people carrying bags that say
chronicon or [ __ ] like that it's a weird
mirror so I figured you know again when
I was cutting the clips for Hall H I was
like what what should I bring and hi I
just thought it'd be [ __ ] up if you
watched another audience watching a
movie in a movie so so I figured I'd
bring the movie within the movie
sequence the blunt man the chronic movie
sequence and in order to do that I
should bring up the person who's in the
sequence man she I asked her two years
ago when I we're working on something
else we were working on an episode of
Supergirl ladies and gentlemen
I asked I say man will you come play in
this movie and she instantly said yeah
it took two years to get there but we
finally did it and she played chronic
she replaced Jason Mewes chronic give up
for Melissa Benoist
[Applause]
so I'll we'll take a peek at the scene
then we'll all sit down and chitchat and
[ __ ] like that man so this is the
sequence hey you're gonna get to see it
writ large this is the sequence of the
movie that takes place at chronicon so
enjoy this weird black mirror version of
tonight ladies jump let's roll that clip
shall we
and it goes on from there man so that's
a little taste of the flick now we're
gonna open it up talk to you guys we'll
have our guests sit here and please feel
free to ask them questions and [ __ ] we
can open up them mics what you think
how'd you how'd it look I gotta be
honest with you man I was I've always
that Brody scene like him and I we go
out on the road we do a show called Jay
and Silent Bob get old a live podcast
and so at all the shows for the last
like two years we would read that scene
like during the show just to test it out
and stuff and and I was able to shape
the scene based on the audience take out
jokes didn't work add things and stuff
like that so we've heard it like ret
we've heard it with an audience read
aloud but we haven't shown the movie to
anybody nobody's really seen it and
stuff except people that worked on it so
that was the first time we showed
anything and I'll admit my [ __ ]
clenched a little [ __ ] bit but once
you guys start laughing I was like all
right we did right we did right all
right who we got man let's open it up
who's our first cue hey Mike hey man we
eat all the time all the time holy [ __ ]
you're my Comic Con buddy how are you
Mike your mic um become buddy I don't
[ __ ] go too far alright did you know
okay let me just tell you there was a
tweet that you did about a young boy
going graduating from high school and
all the audience didn't make a sound
yeah and they respected him with his
autism something like that I think
should it be expand more maybe a
documentary would you ever think about
making a documentary about just the nerd
culture has the kids that have autism
and can't take that noise or some of
them get hyper hyper excited and for me
that's something that uh I mean that was
just amazing and I just some I feel like
I I wouldn't want to make a movie like
that and what's your feeling about a
documentary about kids that that are
nerds and that love this stuff but yet
have a hard time listening to the cheers
because the the crayons are they get too
excited and people find them weird and
as a fan I I don't like seeing
other people put that person down yeah
thanks me yeah it does it's kinda Thea's
runs deep in you man that's awesome
especially here man you'd imagine
there's nothing but inclusion here and
stuff and that's what we always tell
people in the world but I'm sure we're
all human beings and I'm sure there are
people that don't mean to hurt other
people's feelings it's something how I
end up doing it stuff's just impossible
it's like trying not to step on grass or
ants in this world somebody's gonna be
hurt by your actions by somebody else's
actions and it's hard not to feel that
when you got a heart like yours man
Marcos out to you would I do a
documentary about that no but my niece
Sabine is autistic and that nerd girl
she's into the culture and way into film
she's in college right now taking film
so that's something that if she wanted
to make if she wanted to showcase I'd
help her a hundred percent or but you
know yeah that's about the most you
can't a hundred I was gonna say a
thousand but that's a lie a hundred
percent I'd help her so if she's into it
I'm ready to help her do whatever she
wants to do cuz she's into film that
just excites me when Harley announced
that she was into film that excited me
cuz I realized it was gonna go past me
like I felt that I was I was a fluke I
didn't come from the movie biz I didn't
know anybody in the movie biz and like
my dad was a postal worker and [ __ ] my
mom was a homemaker so like you know
I've in many ways felt like an astronaut
you know did a moon shot with clerks and
[ __ ] lived in space ever since so I
didn't think there'd be other
generations that never occurred to me or
there'd be somebody else in my family
and stuff but when the kid said like she
was into it I was like oh my god we
might have like two generations in the
entertainment business like that would
be amazing
and now that my niece is in the
filmmaking same thing so anything she
wants to do I'll support I don't know if
she wants to talk about her autism you
know like most people who have something
probably want to talk about something
else
but if she wants to BAM I'm right there
for it and stuff you got a great hard
day but see how are you captain good man
captain like Captain America America's
ass
yeah that was quick that really I don't
think of you as America's ass it is I
saw that movie as well yes so did 7,000
people yes this good point we all saw
that no we all got in [ __ ] I just didn't
want you thinking I thought you were
America's ass
you could have America's ass how old are
you I'm 18 I was gonna tell you to turn
around I assume you have America's ass
I'd [ __ ] love that let's do it it's I
like end up bringing up Avengers I
noticed in your trailer you have a
fellow Avengers end game co-star along
with two familiar faces like I noticed
you have Chris Hemsworth Matt Damon Ben
Affleck and all those guys how did you
talk to him into joining your film I
don't know I'm still [ __ ]
flabbergasted by it when I watched the
trailer I'm impressed and [ __ ] how did
Chris Hemsworth happen that was he Chris
had said something in an interview and
bandi fair when thor ragnarok was out
where he mentioned listening to one of
the podcasts of Kevin Smith and that he
knew my name at all I was like oh my god
the god of thunder knows my name and
[ __ ] so I put it in a mental checklist
like if he knows who I am like I could
always reach out you know cuz at least
he I wouldn't be reaching out and have
him go like who like you'd be like oh
that's the guy that said some [ __ ] on a
podcast and stuff so sooner or later we
came around to the film and I asked
Jason's wife Jordan's the producer I was
like somebody reach out to Chris
Hemsworth man like he said something
about us like at one point like in that
thing so we did and and this is how
beautiful life is his agent I think it
was or his manager got the call and was
just like there was silence after Jordan
said yeah we were interested in seeing
if Chris Hemsworth Kevin Smith had seen
him say something about him have an
affair and Kevin was interested to see
if Chris wanted to come play and Jay and
Silent Bob reboot she said there's a
long pause on the phone and then the guy
said do you know I'm in the movie
business because of
clerks you know and [ __ ] like that pays
off like you never know what you do
right now how it pays off in the future
I made clerks for me lazy John it wasn't
altruistic it wasn't like I hope this
makes a bunch of people make their art I
was just a kid that was desperate to
make his art I saw people making movies
and it seemed [ __ ] fun and I want to
be a part of it and they were people and
I was a people it wasn't like they had
any special abilities they can come from
[ __ ] space so like if they were doing
it I could do it too
so you know to kind of dream it and then
[ __ ] do it and then see it what was
my point I just felt I hit up but you
when Jordan called the guy said clerks
thank you so well done [ __ ] egg and
now you see why I'm usually silent Bob
because that movie that like I made for
me and stuff it just spoke to people
right like I've met people my whole life
who were like I started what I do
because I watched that movie when I was
a kid or some [ __ ] like that so in this
case it really helped out like that
person was just like I'm gonna try to
help this happen and stuff and it helped
it that Chris was willing to do it
who built time into his schedule like he
came to us on the day there's a morning
we only needed him for like a nap we
only used him for 20 minutes on a green
screen but he gave us like this two-hour
window but we got him in and out because
he had a bunch of [ __ ] to do and I hate
to have people sitting around and [ __ ]
and you know once you get the selfie
it's all over anyway so so you know I
was once he got there we were prepping
you know his green screen so it was
already kind of prepped and whatnot and
so we were chit-chatting outside and I
was like you must have a busy day and he
listed like two TV shows two big TV
shows that he was about to go do one of
which was Ellen I think one was Jimmy
Kimmel he's like and then we're getting
on a jet we go to London for the
premiere and then from London he listed
four things so in the span of like 28
hours he was going to be doing really
important pricey [ __ ] [ __ ] that
required jet fuel and and so that he
broke off anytime for us was like
[ __ ] amazing and so I was thanking
him I was like Jesus when he heard the
schedule was like [ __ ] thanks man
and he said the sweetest thing and mind
you you know it was sweet to me I may be
sweet a balance he goes
was the thing I was looking forward to
doing the most this weekend
that's how good an actor four is ladies
and gentlemen that was Hemsworth Matt we
reached out to and and Matt had been
taking a break and had been away but
then once he got the message got right
back to us and stuff Ben I never reached
out to and didn't even ride him into the
movie originally because I hadn't spoken
to him in like eight years at that point
so there was no you know Jay and Silent
Bob strike back Ben played Ben Affleck
and he also played Holden McNeil in this
there was gonna be no Ben Affleck and no
Ben Affleck jokes and there was gonna be
no Holden McNeil or anything like that
as you see Brodie in this movie takes
the job that that Holden kind of had in
the last movie where he sets the boys on
their mission and stuff that's how
resolu that's how I felt like he's
saying he's not coming back man so I
didn't even build them into it this is a
story I've told it all all weekend long
out in the world ball is doing press but
I'll do it here for you guys the this is
a story about how like entertainment
journalism can make the difference a lot
of people think is dopey and [ __ ] like
that I've always loved entertainment
journalism my favorite kind of
journalism is in the [ __ ] world
whenever I look at real journalism I
usually get sad because the world can be
a terrible place but not an
entertainment you know it's always
hopeful they're like look this [ __ ]
movies coming you know like holy [ __ ] I
can't wait and you pay to see the movie
you're [ __ ] tricked again but
but it don't matter because there's
another movie coming down the way and
stuff like that so I've always loved
entertainment journalism like when
Entertainment Tonight started I was
right there I remember recording video
recording the Batman trailer of 1989's
Tim Burton Batman trailer and watching
it on VHS over and over even with the
Entertainment Tonight like logos on it
and the voice-over ch it didn't matter
man it was a window and entertaining and
to Entertainment so I've always loved
entertainment journalism always kind of
liked it didn't realize it could be
important to there's a guy named Kevin
McCarthy really sweet kid who's out of
Washington DC I say kid because he's
younger than me but he's a grown-ass
adult and [ __ ] he's on TV and he
interviews people at junkets he's the
entertainment guy and exam I see him he
talks about the movies I've done he's
big view askew fan and stuff and even
though we haven't made view askew movies
for a year he'd all of years he'd he'd
always bring him up and he'd send my son
and he'd bring it up to any people he
saw like in the world where he was
interviewing people and stuff so if he
was interviewing Matt Damon for some
other movie a Bourne movie like he would
lead with like a man when you make a
good will hunting 3 and Matt be like
good will hunt oh [ __ ] him Kevin yeah
that's right and [ __ ] and it always put
him a little you know like a tease
because oh this guy must know that guy
and stuff like that so anybody he sits
with he usually kind of that I've worked
with he opens with a view askew type
thing so Kevin McCarthy interviewed Ben
while we were two weeks into production
on Jay and Silent Bob reboot we only had
two weeks left to go we were deep into
our story and everything had been cast
and when we started the movie we didn't
know if we'd get people to come down and
do cameos and stuff because we were
shooting in Louisiana but since we were
shooting during Mardi Gras people were
like [ __ ] yeah and everybody came
because it was a [ __ ] free trip to
Mardi Gras man so like we got like a
ninja and saw Bob strike back we have 22
single cards at the end of the movie for
the cast and cameos in Jay and Silent
Bob reboot 44 [ __ ] cards like way
more people showed up and that's the
heart attack impact right there ladies
and gentlemen that's a lot of people
like me going hey man come be in my
movie and their first instinct is like
[ __ ] no but then they're like he almost
[ __ ] died
and then they came and [ __ ] played
and stuff like that so in terms of you
know reaching out to people and whatnot
Ben was not somebody I was ever gonna
reach out to but Kevin McCarthy sitting
down with Ben to do an interview for a
junket for Netflix this movie called
triple frontier that Ben was it and so
yeah you've seen it so Kevin McCarthy
his first thing off the bat he just says
to Ben just as like you know a warm-up a
world of her [ __ ] hey have they called
you for reboot yet and Ben goes no they
haven't and I'm available and our world
stopped you know everyone in production
you know because it was on Twitter and
people like did you [ __ ] see this and
I was like oh oh that's nice you know
it's nice but that's some nice [ __ ] you
say to junk it you know like people say
[ __ ] to me all the time and I'm like
yeah of course but inside I'm like I
hate that prick you know like it's just
some nice [ __ ] to say at a junket that's
not worth following up on and they were
like you should you should really poke
around you should why don't you reach
out to him call him I was like I haven't
spoken about in eight years I haven't
spoke to Ben in a long long time and
worked with him since like clerks to
he'd never read badan been in one of our
flicks but I didn't just even spoken to
him as person for like eight years and
stuff I thought our friendship was dead
and I never wanted to reach out and find
out I was right you know it's one thing
to think like this [ __ ] just
don't like me anymore because I'll never
hear from this person is another thing
to have that confirmed if you're like
hey [ __ ] you like me anymore and
they're like [ __ ] no you know suddenly
you're carrying that like a cross for
the rest of your life so you know I was
better to live in ignorance ignorance
was bliss and [ __ ] and so my people were
pushing me to pop that balloon ignorance
you know and potentially open myself to
up to harm to heartbreak and [ __ ] and
I've had enough [ __ ] heartbreak so
I'm like I don't want to [ __ ] do that
like I ain't gonna bother the guy we got
our plans we got a movie to make and
like everything's going fine we got the
money for this movie without them we
don't need holdin to tell the story like
we're doing just fine I'm not reaching
out and we made the movie for another
week and then they kept poking me and I
kept ignoring it and then it just
started to sit on my chest that I was it
wasn't about the movie I was just scared
like I just didn't want to be rejected I
just didn't want to reach out and find
out for sure that he was like [ __ ] you
because I'd always wondered like all
those years we made those movies didn't
they mean anything like they meant
something to me
didn't they mean anything to him like we
never hear from him anymore
so I never wanted to reach out finally
I write this tweet that I'm gonna send
and there's an and Jordan thankfully
Jays wife Bruce are on the movie right
before I sent it she read it and she
said don't don't tweet that just like
text it to him and I was like I [ __ ] I
got a bunch of old numbers they probably
don't work like that'd be weird and
invasive to send him a text she's going
it'd be weird attacked to send him a
tweet in public and [ __ ] I was like good
point good point and so I texted him and
and this this is what I had texted man I
texted a bunch of [ __ ] and I won't read
you that but I closed up and it's
relevant to this room because it's from
[ __ ] Conan the Barbarian I said but
to paraphrase the sad old king Osric and
Conan the Barbarian there comes a time
when the jewels ceased to Sparkle when
the gold loses its luster when the
throne room becomes a prison and all
that's left is the directors love for
the people he used to make pretend with
I sent him that text and I [ __ ]
waited with a clenched [ __ ] last time
last time I spoke to my friend I was a
different person all together you know I
was that Kevin Smith now I'm that Kevin
Smith and I've mellowed out incredibly
I've always been fairly mellow but
[ __ ] once I became a stoner ten years
ago Jesus Christ I have no pulse
whatsoever man I'm you know very little
gets me upset or excited and [ __ ] and I
run deep fast you know I could talk to
the Russo brothers I terrified both of
them when I went up to him separately I
met Anthony first at a different event
altogether their deadly class show
sci-fi had an event I met him there and
[ __ ] he was like hey thanks for hosting
the event and I was like do you
understand that end game movie gave me
my dead father back because it reminded
me of when I used to go to the movies
with my father as a child
and Anthony Russo went so [ __ ] white
like holy [ __ ] it's it's just a movie
bro and and I was like no no no you
killed Thanos and brought Don Smith back
to life with a snap like so when I met
his brother we shot something for the
IMDB and we did it with the russo as a
pre shoot for you know this weekend
coming up the IMD IMD boat stuff we did
and so I shot with the Russos and so
Anthony had met me and gone through the
experience and you could tell when I
came over and I was like oh it's the
Russos and he goes this is my brother
Joe and he introduces me to Joe mind you
Anthony told me at the party he's gone
like I love comics but Joe is the one
that got me into comics Joe bleeds comic
books everything that is magical about
those movies comes from [ __ ] Joe so
as hard and deep as I went on Anthony I
[ __ ] like practically blew Joe Russo
you know like just I was like you don't
understand my father's been dead for 15
[ __ ] years like he can't take me to
the movies anymore and you brought him
back to life I was sitting next to me
and [ __ ] like and he was like Jesus
Christ thanks man thanks a lot like so I
run deep and hard and whatnot and I was
afraid that the thing I'd sent to him
he's like quoting Conan what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you he's like no wonder Ivan
reached out to this fool but my old
friend who I came up with like who I
share created the creative DNA with who
I dreamt on my [ __ ] couch while we
made chasing amy and [ __ ] like that who
I first saw in Mallrats and was just
like why don't you [ __ ] leading man
man like you're charming and funny and
[ __ ] funniest [ __ ] dude I know you
should be like the lead in movies I'm
gonna write you [ __ ] lead in movie
first time the guy that I met you know
the first day in an audition for mall
rats where he came in and I just read
about him and his buddies selling a
script to Castle Rock in The Hollywood
Reporter and I was a gay man
congratulations I saw you guys sold the
spec script he looked at me shot go and
like how do you [ __ ] know that I was
like oh I read the trades he goes you
care about that [ __ ] I was like I'm yeah
like the entertainment business
entertainment journalism fascinates me
congratulations and [ __ ] and he goes
you're a [ __ ] fan aren't
I just met the [ __ ] guy man and right
away I knew I liked him that guy who I
hadn't reached out to for all that time
so I was terrified what he'd say he
wrote back
this and it was so perfectly Ben he
wrote back of course you still liken
yourself to a king and I right then and
there kids I felt safe I felt so safe I
was like oh my god
I don't care what he says next I don't
care if he says he's busy for the next
10 years the guy used to joke around
with and [ __ ] just texted me the way we
used to talk to each other you got to
understand the ending of our
relationship predated SMS I don't think
I've ever shared a text with Ben Affleck
and [ __ ] like that
that was like I framed that [ __ ] like it
meant the world to me and so I said do
you want to come out and play and I said
we're all having a blast here in the
past man you want to come out and play
and he said I would love to and he came
out not only did he come out to do the
flick man I didn't know what to cast him
in because we'd cast everything there
was nothing really left and I was like
oh maybe I could make up a part maybe I
could stick him in this scene or
something like that
all of it seemed like a waste because he
was coming he didn't even like Vegas do
it in LA he's like I'll come to New
Orleans and so he was making the trip
New Orleans sorry so he was making the
trip so I was like [ __ ] I fell asleep
one night thinking about I was like
Jesus man I haven't seen my ears and
he's willing to get on a plane come down
here and shoot the scene well you don't
even know what it is I said I should do
something special [ __ ] so next morning I
texted him I was like would you mind
playing Holden again and he was like I
was hoping you would say that and so I
said all right give me give me a minute
I think I could come up with something
and I wrote an 8 page sequel to chasing
a me like that just follows up like 20
years later and [ __ ] like that
and functions perfectly within the movie
if you see the movie you'll be like wait
that scene didn't exist when you started
the [ __ ] movie why would you have
bothered and [ __ ] it is the emotional
culmination of the movie and sends us
into a really great place so he came and
did the scene man like is eight pages
when I sent him the scene first thing he
texted back was like bro I have not done
this much dialogue in the last three
movies I was in I was like too much he
goes no I think I can handle it but my
favorite thing that he wrote was he goes
you've changed there's an awful lot of
italics in my [ __ ] now and I had to
explain I was like because now I write
in a computer program not a typewriter I
can italicize [ __ ] like that which you
know I used to always tell the kids how
to act I give line readings like crazy
first learned what it was like we did it
on clerks like you tell the actors like
saying like this this is way I heard it
when I wrote it just say it like this
and [ __ ] and then on Mallrats I did it
once to shannen doherty she was doing
their line wrong to my ear and [ __ ] and
I was like not the way I wrote it
so I said Shannon do me a favor just say
it like this and I said the line back to
her and Shannon was appalled and she
looks at me she goes did you just give
me a line reading and I was like is that
what it's called yes then that's what I
did and she goes actors hate line
readings I was like really she's like
yeah it's insulting and [ __ ] like that
oddly enough years [ __ ] later we're
on the set of Jay and Silent Bob reboot
and we shoot a scene and it's like the
girls outside with me and Jay and you
know I'm doing the coverage when I'm not
in the coverage and it's hardly
on-camera and she says the line
differently than I heard it when I read
it and [ __ ] so I go in the middle of
take Harley do me a favor just say it
like this and I said the line out to her
and for the first time in 24 [ __ ]
years I saw the expression that shannen
doherty had that day
and I was like oh my god and so I tried
to work around it and then we cut at a
certain point and I saw the kid like
kind of off to the side and I came over
and talked to her I was like how you
doing kiddo she's like you gave me a
line reading I said I did she's going in
front of everybody do you know how
insulting that is to an actor
I said I know you're right you know what
I've heard that I've heard actors don't
like I've heard it for [ __ ] years
that actors don't like it I said but you
know and I've been an actor sometimes
and I love it when a director gives me a
line reading because then I know I'm
gonna if I do it right I'm definitely
gonna be in the [ __ ] movie but I'm
honestly here to tell you and I ain't
just doing this to save face like I was
wrong like I didn't trust the kid on
yoga hoser she was a kid she'd never
really done it except for tusk so I was
still in the mode that I was when I was
younger where I was like just do it like
this say it like this it was easy back
then when she was kid I was like oh say
it like this
she pair it back between the time we did
yoga hosers and Jay and Silent Bob
reboot she became an actress she went to
like Stella Adler classes studied and
[ __ ] like that
she's in Quentin's new movie once upon a
time in Hollywood and stuff so the
little kid that I was like just saying
it like this was looking at me like what
the [ __ ] is your problem
you're no Quentin Tarantino I'll tell
you that and she was right man like my
instincts were like you better say it
like I heard it in my head but I didn't
really hear Millie when I wrote the
character man like when I wrote Millie I
didn't put a lot of flesh on the bones
cuz I was like you know what the kid
will figure it out I had all the faith
in the world the kid would figure it out
by the time we got to the set the kid
was making choices where I was like she
figured it [ __ ] wrong
you know like on day one then by day two
I was like oh oh I I like this like the
idea was like Jennifer my wife asked me
when I got home on the first day she was
like how did Harley do and I was like
well she was acting like really well and
my wife will goes that's great and I was
like well we're all making a comedy and
she was acting man like like she's in a
we're in a cartoon she's in a real
we somehow like I don't have the heart
to tell her like this is Jay and silly
Bob and [ __ ] like that
she thinks she's still on Quentin set
and thank God she did it because her
character like really grounds the movie
she's very real in the flick and whatnot
and not grounds it in a way where it's
like some [ __ ] funny you give a [ __ ]
man
because she's so [ __ ] real and her
chemistry with Jay winds up being
[ __ ] wonderful
so Affleck says he's coming man and he
says there's a lot of italics in his
[ __ ] and I say that's because I give
line readings but I don't give a line
readings anymore and [ __ ] like that and
so he shows up and he's I didn't know
who I was getting right like I didn't
know if it was I assumed I get the Ben
Affleck that made Argo for Christ's
sakes I didn't know if I'd get Batman
but I knew I'd at least get the director
you know like the [ __ ] guy who knows
how to make a film last time we worked
together he hadn't even made Gone Baby
Gone yet at that point like he directed
some shorts but Lee hadn't directed a
feature so I didn't know who was gonna
get off the plane join us on set and the
eight pages being what they were I was
like man if I get half of this [ __ ] I'll
be a happy [ __ ] camper if Hold'em
shows up at all like [ __ ] this is a
win and set so he comes I see him for
the first time in years I [ __ ] hug
him and melt in his arms and cry he goes
you smoked too much weed now man he's
gone I said am i overly emotional he
goes you were always a crier so we
chit-chatted we got to know each other
again and [ __ ] then we went to set
because we were on a schedule it was the
last day of the movie all of this
happened on the last day of production
and [ __ ] we had to shoot 8 pages and we
had 5 other scenes to do so he shows up
we go for a blocking Joey's there as
well so they're working together for the
first time since [ __ ] chasing Amy
Jason's there as well and I'm there as
well so it's like the four of us were
there in 1996 when we made that [ __ ]
movie and stuff we all hugged and bonded
then I send everyone else on the crew
way so we can have like a blocking
rehearsal just by ourselves which like
the way we used to do in the old days
just the actors and the director and
[ __ ] like that
so we go for the block is very simple
blocking we walk into a room and spoke
and stand there and that's about it and
stuff so we go through the blocking and
setting it up and Joey has her
which is a small version of the script
in her hands and stuff like that jason
has his sides because he's got a lot of
dialogue I had my sides and I'm silent
Bob and I have no lines but I still had
a set asides in Mianus [ __ ] Ben didn't
have asides so I was like you want you
want a set asides because I think I got
it and I was like all right we were just
blocking so it didn't matter in [ __ ] I
was like let's run the scene man top to
bottom and he [ __ ] knew every line of
every one of those eight pages including
a two-page [ __ ] monologue like
verbatim and [ __ ] he could have done the
monologue backwards completely if I was
a go to the end and say it backwards he
knew every [ __ ] line I almost cried
because I did cry because
he was working the way we work together
back in 1996 like he got on a plane and
was like Oh
in order to do Kevin's movie I have to
know every single word of dialogue
because that one time he yelled at us
because we didn't know every word in the
script and [ __ ] like that which is true
I'm chasing him he went in to rehearse
one day and like Joey Ben and Jason were
[ __ ] around they didn't know all the
words and [ __ ] and I was like you know
what everyone go home we're about to
start shooting this movie and nobody's
being serious about it just everyone go
home and read your lines and learn your
lines and Ben was like I've never seen
you mad in my life and I was like that's
as mad as I ever got it was like yeah
you just see him [ __ ] dissapoint it's
like a dad so he went off and read the
entire script and learned the entire
script so the dude who came to join us
in New Orleans were in New Orleans thank
you
memorize like the entire scene had it
down absolutely cold which was insanely
touching like I told him I was like if
you would give me half of that [ __ ] I
would have been a happy camper he's like
the words were important bro they've
always been important and he's going
this time around you finally wrote some
decent [ __ ] for me to say
and it was [ __ ] magic is actually one
of the best scenes the movies one of the
finest pieces of cinema I've ever been
involved with in my life and and Kevin
McCarthy asking that question on the
junket was responsible for that and that
improved the movie vastly it elevated
the movie men but more importantly he
gave me my [ __ ] friend back by asking
that question he gave me back a huge
piece of my heart that been missing for
eight [ __ ] years man just by asking
that dippy question and [ __ ] did they
call you about reboot yet and [ __ ] like
that
change my [ __ ] world give it up for
Kevin McCarthy all right you've been
waiting patiently sir what do you want
to know well uh last time I saw you was
actually at the Avengers end game
premiere it's kind of when you're
talking about Chris Hemsworth and
everything and that's how you got in and
he was my date or I'm like not my date
but he the day that we shot that
yeah Harley was my was the day that we
shot the piece like he was like I'll see
you at the Avengers premiere and I was
like why he's like you're not going I
was like they don't ask me to go to that
[ __ ] and he goes oh come with four and I
was like [ __ ] I wanna but we could go to
the movie too
[Laughter]
so yeah we got to go see n game and sure
there was that delightful it the last
time I saw mr. Jason Mewes was actually
kind of an awkward moment and I just
want to say I love you J man
I think I'm awesome I'm a fellow toy
collector I'm a big-time toy collector I
know you are too but uh I I rudely
walked by you at a 7-eleven because
you're dancing at the counter
and I didn't know is J do you do that in
real life too he does that [ __ ] real
life sometimes I hope they do it when
you get paid man if you're giving it
away for free nobody's gonna see the
[ __ ] movie sometimes I get excited
and I'll dance at the gate for what you
look [ __ ] hot dogs yeah I don't know
I'm not sure at that moment I'm not sure
it depends it depends I work part-time
in the Tenderloin in San Francisco so
like in and yes San Francisco what's up
and I just thought he was a junkie right
there just dancing for no reason I had
no idea
he's mad a lot man I just scooted by him
and then my friend Spencer over here was
like dude like you know those Jason used
and I'm like what what over there he's
like dude that was Jeff Jeff sang Bob I
ain't no [ __ ] away I feel like a dick
so it's like I just wanted to say I love
you man I think I think you're
incredible so I feel like a dick hole
right on but you were right there was a
junkie dancing at down there don't worry
[Applause]
my question is and I think you may have
touched on this topic with a Batman
Beyond episode with mark but I want to
know if you had ever gotten the
opportunity to direct a Marvel Studios
film what film would that be or which
character would you like to direct in in
a film I'd like this sounds like a
cop-out answer but I really don't want
to like it seems really hard and
expensive and seriously like you talked
to the Russo brothers it takes like a
long time and I don't have that kind of
patience I love doing Supergirl that
sounds dirty they lamented I love
directing episodes of Supergirl because
it's like nine days man you get in nine
days you get out you can't [ __ ] it up
like because it's such an insanely well
oiled machine and I get to play with
people in costumes so it like exercises
that part of the brain of like oh man to
work with heroes and [ __ ] and honestly
like I don't care who it is and could be
anybody the better to work with than
Melissa and a costume and [ __ ] she's so
wonderful so I've never really thought
about it when it comes to the Marvel
movies I just want to be somebody that
like watches them I love being a fan
like I love having something that I
don't have to be a part of that I can
love that's a part of my world you know
what I'm saying like just because it
there they make movies and I make movies
doesn't mean that I have to make their
movies and trust me they don't want me
to make their movies and stuff they love
me to talk about their movies and they
were very sweet enough to like drop a
reference to me in Captain Marvel with
the Mallrats Krypton ship which was
insanely [ __ ] sweet and like was was
everything like with a stand of it all
just made it wonderful and whatnot like
when we put stand in Mallrats
back in 1995 believe it or not there was
a period of time where not a lot of
people knew who Stan was like our
parents did and those of us who were
hardcore into comics did but they hadn't
made a Marvel movie so it's not like he
started the series of cameos and stuff
like that so there was a period in time
where I was like hey I introduced him to
a new generation of kids and stuff like
that and then with Captain Marvel he
kind of returned the favor because he
introduced me to a whole new bunch of
people who like Jay and silly-- what you
know like [ __ ] I never heard of us
anything like that so it was kind of
sweet so that's enough for me honestly
like [ __ ] you know like at one point
when I heard about Captain Marvel before
I saw the movie Kevin Feige had called
me up and they would they would get the
phone call he answer like hello and
they're like Kevin Feige calling and I
was like oh my god [ __ ] you I want to
talk to him cuz it really don't matter
like Kevin Feige is pure [ __ ] Joy's
greatest storyteller working like maybe
the greatest storyteller of my life he's
told the massive story over ten years
he's about to tell more [ __ ] stories
in the same realm and [ __ ] if I can love
it to death and stuff so they could call
up and be like Kevin Feige is about to
tell you that he's [ __ ] your mom I'd
be like that's cool I've always wanted
him as a dad you know so I answered and
I was like hey man oh what's up and he's
like how are you and I was like I'm
doing good we chitchat for a minute and
stuff and then he goes alright he's
going I got to tell you something he
first he talked about like Stan had
passed and so he talked about the
episode of fat man beyond that we did at
the scum and villainy Cantina where we
did a Stan eulogy and stuff so he's like
I watched that episode was real good I
said I saw you're at scram posters real
beautiful and [ __ ] and he's going I in
order to have the rest of this
conversation I give you spoiler
information and I was like [ __ ] a man
and he goes you keep it between us
I said ah yes
it's out now so I could talk about it so
he goes okay we've shot stands two last
cameos there in the can and he's gone
and one of them turned out really well
the one for their Avengers endgame it's
real well turned out great and stuff
the last the other one we shot for
Captain Marvel Stan was feeling a little
weak it was toward the end it was toward
the end of his life and I got too few
months away from when he passed away so
they were like Kevin goes his voice was
kind of weak and stuff and I was like ah
that's a shame he's gone now in order to
tell you the rest of the story I got to
tell you some stuff about cap Marvel
that nobody knows and stuff I said okay
he's gone it stands cameo in the movie
and I was like all right and this is
early this is like three four months
before the movie came out so I was like
do talent [ __ ] and he goes all right so
Captain Marvel it put punches through a
train and she's looking for a scroll and
I was what the [ __ ] like that was huge
to me I was like always yeah the first
time I heard there's gonna be scroll so
my god he's a gas man's [ __ ] scroll
he's gone knew you'd like that he's gone
anyway it likes looking first girl and
she comes across he's first you hear
someone reading the script you hear a
line and then you come up to a person
reading the script and the script is
Mallrats and I was like you know he was
like yeah and Stan's reading Mallrats
script and he's doing rehearsing
essentially his lines for Mallrats and
he's like the movie set in 1995 so it
kind of really worked out for us and I
was like oh my god man like this [ __ ]
rocks and he's gone well it could rock
but I might need your help with this and
at this point I'm like he wants me to be
in the movie
I'm gonna be on the train with Stan it
wasn't that at all because you know when
you shot Stan for that scene in Mallrats
he's gone I worked with Stan many times
he's going Stan was not a one take
wonder he had to do it a few times he's
going I assumed it was the same way back
with mall rats I said yeah oh yeah we
had cue cards for him and stuff we did a
few takes and he goes well I would love
those other takes because we have stand
practising his lines and he's saying
trust me true believer and I was like I
[ __ ] wrote that line he goes I know I
know but you're not getting any money
for it he's gone so he's saying that
line but like it'd be great if we can
use a robust version he said what we did
was we burned a version from the
Mallrats DVD and it sounds a lot better
and stuff is more crisp and it sounds a
lot like Stan so we figured you might
have alternative take sounds like
they're definitely alternative takes
Universal has a mountain out and they
don't let me keep that [ __ ] I said but
to be fair Universal may not know that
they own the movie that was true at one
point we tried to get him all rats
licensed for something and they were
like we own that movie from Universal
and they're like all right give us a
week and then the lawyer came back to
chuck at diamond chuck told me the story
he's like I asked about getting the mall
rats license he's like and I work with
Universal all the time it's like
Jurassic and [ __ ] like that he's like
then the lawyer got back to me and he
was just like uh we'll give you the mall
rats license for five grand and he's
like five grand that's cheap why and he
goes uh mall rats was made before the
computer error so it's on paper like all
the deals are on paper and those are all
in a [ __ ] warehouse somewhere and
it'll cost more to hire somebody to go
out and find those [ __ ] papers
then it would be just to say five grand
and chuck was like I'll give you ten
he's like sold and so the mall rights
license was up for grabs yet they didn't
really knew they know they knew the
movie and [ __ ] what was the point of
that story why was I talking about mall
rats about to him asking for a favor
because Stan was on the train and I
thank you so I said you called Universal
Man they might have two takes and stuff
like that and he was like excellent he
goes please don't tell anybody ever
about this conversation I was like I
won't what was a great moment was it did
I answer that question or no I did right
yeah how are you what do you want to
know man so great to see you the rest of
you - it's awesome to see you here
Melissa you look super badass in your
new suit doesn't the suit look [ __ ]
dope tell him about the suit you've
actually worn it was it your idea to put
the picture out when he'd win it went
out was a New York yeah yeah cuz we were
about to shoot an exterior scene the
next day and I knew someone was gonna
take a picture in Vancouver of it and I
didn't want anyone else to spoil it is
that what happens like you guys you're
constantly getting shot in the real
world like people are kind of because
you shootout in Vancouver all the time
yeah over you I just wanted to give a
quick shout out to my older cousin
Brendan he's about three years older
than me and he's the one who introduced
me to all your stuff he showed me a Jay
and Silent Bob strike back when I was
age not age-appropriate I was like 10 or
11 and I were giving him a shout-out in
prison no he's good he's all he's fine
good yeah
he's totally cool enough however he has
done the tuck in front of me a handful
of time so J that one that one's for you
to look what you [ __ ] did yes we even
actually also tried our hand at
podcasting for a couple years back like
I did about like 35 to 40 episodes and
so that was it was fun was it fun yeah
so my question is I really love a lot of
like your song cues in your movies my
personal favorite being 1979 my Punk by
the Smashing Pumpkins in Kirk's too so I
was curious as to you know what your
what your process is for you know
choosing what songs to put in your
movies and if the if the rest you want
to chime in you know what your own
personal favorite you know song needle
drop is in one of Kevin's movies how do
I choose my usually as an afterthought
never in advance like the you know we
got lucky we got a Pearl Jam track in
the movie daughter and that came like
while I was in the editing room never
thought to use and [ __ ] even though it
kind of has something to do with the
movie although if you listen to the
lyrics not really and just good for the
title and then so I kind of put it into
a cut early on in the flick and knowing
that like we're gonna lose this there's
no way we could afford this song cuz you
know the songs cost money and shed and
that one's well known and they're well
known and stuff they're also known to
like they have to approve stuff Eddie
has to approve things they don't just
give out the music necessarily even if
you have the money for it so it didn't
feel like it was ever something that was
gonna be real beyond like the kind of
temp cut that I was working on but we
were able to kind of push the ball
forward right to the finish line and we
wound up getting the song at a pretty
reasonable rate and stuff like that it's
beautiful in the movie but it was always
an after thought it was me sitting there
going oh daughter you know if I can put
it in
so I I don't give it a hell of a lot of
thought until we're kind of I've got
something to cut to and then it's mostly
stuff that primarily comes off of my
iPod and then later on people make
suggestions for stuff but I'm not like
Quentin like Quentin writes the songs
into the movie and stuff like that John
Hughes used to do the same thing for
what I understand soundtrack was a big
part of the writing process for him but
for me it's usually an afterthought kids
goodbye that's my favorite of course in
that that's my favorite too what I just
seen I don't I don't care to see the
scene that goes along with it I don't
need to see you talk but I love the song
it must have been weird to see him tuck
I've been seeing him my whole life but
that was a first for you yeah we covered
her eyes I told her to cover our eyes
when we did it so you don't even get to
really see it when we shot it so that
might have that's probably the first
time you see I just saw it on a huge
screen and the word though or more to
the point you didn't see it well the
good thing is I'm glad this weekend we
were able to mention something that you
didn't know and now you can make sure
you stay clear she has never seen Zack
and Miri Make a Porno I was that we were
talking about it I was like yeah I did
pull frontal she's like wad so
thankfully you didn't just go hey I'm
gonna check this movie on dad's
collection and all sudden that would
have been yeah if we're talking about
your dick in front of my kid awkward is
just going on and on there's Ops am glad
now she'll never watch that please don't
there's also a scene with your full bare
ass in reboot so I did see that up front
and personal on the first day of
shooting I mean booties funny stink
nugget
unless you got a favorite move music you
in anything yeah the wookie song in the
first clerks Wow well remembered
Chewbacca
listen was sweet when I would talked
about her being in the flick like she
said she's you used to watch the other
one the change that black chick back
yes I've seen all your movies to be
responsive you kind of can't believe I'm
sitting up here hey oh wow smoochie boo
cheese I waited five years to say that
and you're gonna hear from our lawyer
got a say trademark after that anyways I
just noticed this place was completely
full and I've never seen it full before
so congratulations for that there's
chairs over there
there's our staff that's the Marvel
section [ __ ] going it's good anyways
when I watch movies I know she'll always
have cameos and when I watched the
trailer I had noticed Batman in FAL
Kilmer did you like plan out did you
notice in that scene that it's we've got
Batman and Supergirl playing Bluntman
and chronic yeah that's it I was
delighted by the in Thor and fake Loki
which is bad yes
which also played Loki cousins we got
him as well yeah double Loki hit on them
yeah but do you ever like when you're
making the movie or like oh this guy
would be great for this cameo or
he'd be a great one for this and do you
ever how's that process go it's
nerve-wracking like the process of
getting the cast together on Jay and
Silent Bob reboot was nerve-wracking for
for everybody I tried not to think about
it I was trying to think about like hey
day by day we're making the movie but
when we went to New Orleans we didn't
have the full cast in place I think it
was me J and Harley Melissa had said yes
diedrich bader had said yes and Jason
Biggs
said yes and that was it so we didn't
know who else was gonna be there if
other people were to come then Jason Lee
said yes so we knew we had him and stuff
like that so we put it together slowly
and we didn't think it was gonna work
out because when we shot strike back we
were in Los Angeles so you can just call
people like can you roll down a Sweetzer
and shoot something like [ __ ] yeah cuz
they were all in the same neighborhood
we were gonna be down in Louisiana so
there wasn't necessarily guaranteed to
get people there but because it was
Mardi Gras people were like [ __ ] yeah
and we wound up getting a lot of people
to come travel and mostly everyone we
went after said yeah some people were in
but then couldn't do it
I mean this is kind of a spoiler or non
spoiler because it didn't happen
Macaulay Culkin was gonna play
cock-knocker but then he had a thing
that he had to drop out personal thing
so he couldn't do it and stuff like that
but we got lucky in so many other ways
like it never felt like all the ones we
didn't get were a disappointment we got
very fortunate a lot of people came out
to play thanks Ben
over you well first and foremost has
been always a bucket list item of mine
to ask you a question so I've always
tried at a small cash show and never got
the opportunity so here hole agents
amazing so welcome man yeah thank you
all H is great isn't it
so I've been coming here for [ __ ]
years not just speaking here because I
don't think I spoke here I was talking
to Jen earlier today when we were here
with Jay and Silent Bob strike back we
weren't in Hall H yet I think we're in
like five ABC and D or whatever it's
called and I think it was the next year
they were like hey why don't you go into
Hall H because we packed that room and
they're like you should just go and that
was when like Hall H was half this size
and you could sit in it all day long if
you got a piece of real estate you
didn't have to [ __ ] leave the room
and [ __ ] so like they put me on when
like the year that Peter Jackson was
here for King Kong
that was what closed Hall H that night
that was the big [ __ ] show that's how
they used to do it I was in the middle
like I was just something for an hour to
kind of hold things together I was
delighted to be here because I never
really played to a crowd that pic and
they were they were sitting there it
wasn't like I had to fill the place they
just sat in their seats because they
were sticking around for [ __ ] Peter
Jackson in the evening and stuff so I
was playing to a bunch of people that
didn't care for my [ __ ] didn't know who
I was and she
like that and family as well which I
hadn't really thought about in [ __ ] and
so after that panel they approached me
the folks at comic-con they were very
sweet and they're like we can't have you
do a panel during the day anymore we're
gonna move you to the end of the night
and I was like why man they're like
because you curse a lot
and like they got kids here man and like
one person asked a question about Batman
and you used the phrase [ __ ] smoker in
an answer I was like well they asked
about Robin you know so I was like they
were like it'd be better if you were at
the end of the night and I was like ah
[ __ ] and so like you know I was always
worried because they put you at the end
of the night that means everyone could
leave I was spoiled by people being
there they had to sit through me anyway
and always gave you a chance to convert
a few more people and [ __ ] like that and
maybe weren't into your stuff but being
pushed to the end of the night meant
that oh [ __ ] like people could leave if
they want and stuff in one year they did
JJ took them all and [ __ ] so you know it
is is it possible and still to this day
like I walk out and I'm like oh man I
wonder if anybody's gonna be here when I
see people here I'm [ __ ] to light you
gonna ask Melissa I was backstage and I
went real hard on Melissa and real quick
when I sat next to her I was like we're
friends enough where I could tell you
this I'm about to cry and here's why you
turned and looked me straight I was like
help me Supergirl fly me away and she's
like I don't do that yeah man it was
it's nerve-wracking coming out here like
cuz I'm for some reason inside I've
always hitched this room up to my
relevancy in pop culture so I'm like if
I walk out there and [ __ ] people are
there alright I'm good for another year
of this [ __ ] if I walk out nobody's
there who knows and like you know the
year of [ __ ] force awakens when when
the audience left I was like oh my god
I'm ruined like psychologically that
kind of broke me for a minute and [ __ ]
and then I remembered like it's [ __ ]
Star Wars we all been before Star Wars
and [ __ ] and sit happens and I just
[ __ ] moved on and [ __ ] but nothing
will be as bad as that walking out and
seeing like it's a 6,000 seater and we
had like there's 2,000 people at the end
of the day but 2,000 people and a 6000
senior looks it looks like a [ __ ] hot
dog in a hallway man it's terrifying and
then there were people that you like
that one it's still good to make him
laugh man if you can make the wife laugh
still it's really good
and so there were people do that just
hate my ass a lot like people online
websites Mona who took pictures from the
back door of the entire empty place on
me on stage and only a few rows full and
that [ __ ] hurt and there was a lot of
haha and [ __ ] like that
that's the worst it'll ever be so even
so coming out here tonight I was just
like I don't know why I [ __ ] do this
I set myself for this ever year I don't
have to do this I don't have to [ __ ]
agree to Hall H I can take a smaller
room but no I go whole age engine and
Melissa's like why did I agree to come
and uh but then I walked down there a
bunch of cats here and I was a goner you
know what he made me feel good as he
walked out he goes whoa it's packed and
I know he has no depth perception but
still a [ __ ] you came out there's
like one row oh I would have been so bad
I would have been like what is your idea
of empty like did you just say that to
placate me you're like it's packed no I
really was shot and again I got to come
out and talk and I was like oh my
goodness
I put you out here because I was like
I'm scared if there's nobody out there
you go out there and if I heard all the
clap I was just gonna run and let him do
the show and [ __ ] I'm like Kevin Smith
[Laughter]
for an hour
[Applause]
this guy has not asked his question yet
I also just I'm so sorry
that was justice to the question being
asked
cuz that was we were talking about
[ __ ] Hawley it's my bad I got on a
Hall H - oh [ __ ] but were you here in
Hall H at the time that the Avengers
were here for the first time first time
they ever had the Avengers Assemble
years ago I really want to hear this
keep going it's true story first time
all the Avengers assembled for the movie
comes out they had the only like
incident in Hall Lakes that I've ever
heard of like a fight kind of incident
there was a jockeying for seats and
somebody had pulled out if I understand
correctly a compass you know you put a
compass down and then to make a circle
around like it's got the pointy thing
and they stabbed somebody else in the
Lagon [ __ ] here in Hall H if I remember
correctly and [ __ ] and I remember
thinking like the Avengers were there
and not a one of them did a [ __ ]
thing about it anyway there's a lot of
[ __ ] been happening in this room it's
always nice to be back but she's right
my daughter you have not answered past
your question leave that yes so my
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so with all the Marvel movies we get
great and credit scenes in strike back
we got an epics and credit scene with
more stay in the [ __ ] time is
there an end credits scene in reboot oh
there is there's number one
go ahead he's gotta go to the bathroom
he's so happy with his joke he's like I
get to pee I've earned a urination the
way I did the movie is the movie proper
is about in an hour and the whole movie
experiences an hour and 45 minutes but I
think the hour and 35 37 maybe make up
the movie proper itself from the
beginning to the end of the story but
then during the single cards and well
first we do the whole cast and single
cards is he trying to find a bathroom
[Applause]
that's the closest bug a bathroom
he just forced gulped it all the way to
the back of the round and I hitched my
wagon to that guy's star so we the movie
ends the story ends then we got like the
single cards of everybody who is in it
and stuff then we go to there's a little
Stanley memorial in it as well and then
we go to the rolling credits and during
the rolling credits we play a bunch of
cutscenes so a bunch of stuff that is
totally fun material but just didn't
feel fit into the confines of the story
proper I just rather than just roll
credits and [ __ ] I just [ __ ] roll
credits next two more content so you get
to see a bunch of [ __ ] that we cut out
and then when that all ends there is a
of course a postscript scene which is
one of my favorite [ __ ] things in the
movie it's at the very end of the movie
but it's a big Easter egg and a big love
letter if you've been watching these
movies for like 25 [ __ ] years and
stuff so yeah we keep it going for sure
it's been so long since I got to play
with my old toys again that's what it
was about right we started the movie one
year to the day after I had the heart
attack like February 26 when I had the
heart attack last year and then we
started the movie on February 26 is a
big [ __ ] you to death and [ __ ] like that
and so in putting it together man I got
to go it felt like you like when I had
the heart attack I felt old like cuz
that happens to old people generally
speaking and stuff it just made me feel
[ __ ] old and kind of weak and I just
wanted to feel young again the best way
for me to feel young was like if I go up
to the attic pull down all my old toys
get on the floor and [ __ ] around play
with him again and that's what I did I
pulled out like Dante and and and Holden
and Brody and you know Alyssa and it
just healed my heart it D aged me it was
really kind of beautiful process so I
didn't want it to end and I haven't
touched those characters in a long
[ __ ] time so I wanted to maximize
that as much as I can so I was like [ __ ]
just rolling credits
let's put content through the credits
and stuff so it's an hour and 45 minutes
from top to bottom and once the once it
begins with the cards upfront which even
those are entertaining the view askew
card and stuff it doesn't [ __ ] end
until it goes black and people I get the
[ __ ] out of the theater and stuff so
we're trying to give your
your money's worth and and and I I'm
happy I just got look I'm I'm a Kevin
Smith fan - I'm the first Kevin Smith
fan and probably outside of my mother
the biggest Kevin Smith fan and stuff
and I love it so much so hopefully
you'll dig it - Thank You Man
how are you I'm doing good oh [ __ ]
that's loud I'm doing pretty good
actually
I just want to say clerks is why I
wanted to start her writing scripts and
becoming a filmmaker in general so thank
you for that Kevin thank you for that
thank you for like a lot of people
listen thank you for hearing like
because that movie is a kind of clarion
call be like you can do this too and he
just tried not me maybe not this [ __ ]
thing but do anything you [ __ ] want
like try it this guy was a chimp and he
tried it and it [ __ ] worked out go
ahead and do it I'm the chimp in
question and so I've been doing it for
like 25 [ __ ] years man you just got
to take a step toward that thing like
he's never going to take a step toward
you unfortunately that thing you dream
about doing it will never [ __ ] come
to you help is never coming nobody's
ever gonna be there to guide you
nobody's ever gonna tell you what to do
if you have a dream if you see it you
want to do it all you have to do is step
toward it man like this guy step toward
the bathroom and the way [ __ ] back
sorry I take I go to the bathroom and
I'm like all right I'm going the
bathroom I'm done going to bathroom I'm
like let me see what time it is I look
at my phone there's one thing take off
the dumb hat as all my wife take off the
dumb hat and it's all I could think
about it the whole walk back I'm out of
it she's got an insight into his
marriage
anyway I'm actually you're a different
guy here I thought the same guy was
gonna be up here yeah we were waiting
for you I'm like everyone shut up no no
I don't mean that I mean it take you're
at your answer to a question usually
last a good ten minutes or so five
minutes you know what [ __ ] you and [ __ ]
you just like Tony Stark I gave birth to
my own problems and [ __ ]
back to you I'm not gonna interrupt you
anymore
so I'm actually also a really big fan of
the clerks animated series oh thank you
I was very sad when it went away but I
just want to know my question is do you
plan on doing any more animated series
with the universe or just a completely
original new animated I I hope to number
one we shout out the cartoons very small
ways in the movie number one first of
which is Jays hat the whole time he's
got like two pins on it one as a buddy
cry spin and the other is Bear is
driving which is always on his left side
so throughout the movie if you know the
cartoon you like only she had bearish
driving and also Dave Mandela's in the
movie the guy that we did the clerks
cartoon with Dave Mandela such a [ __ ]
sweetheart man when we make Clerk Jay
and Silent Bob strike back in 2001 I
could mm I was right right oh I don't
know so I was taking pictures well we
made that [ __ ] what was the point of my
story I just hit a [ __ ] them about
the cartoon the animated which I would
love to do and hopefully we'll do it
next because I've been trying to get
this thing going for the kids for the
children no I do always say like watch
because I'd like a lot of times I'll get
kids that like parents with like 10 year
olds are younger and they like well
they're too young to know you and I'm
like clerks animated it was on regular
TV man but I really did do early on
animated see fair enough but there's six
episodes that are out there and I'd love
to do more so
anyway that I've just thrown it out
there it's really there's a chance that
could happen this year I'm working on
something that might actually open the
door to that and so stand by because I
know a lot of people not a lot of people
the audience a lot of people creatively
who were involved are interested to do
it again
Dave Mandel who I created the show with
I mean yeah we did the show with Dave
Dave went on to run veep for a while on
stuff so now he's done with veep I don't
know there's a chance maybe we can hook
him back into this and stuff but Dave
was in Jay and Silent Bob strike back he
came out and when we tried to get on the
bus
he's sitting there drinking two cups of
coffee like over and over again and [ __ ]
so we were working on this movie and at
one point we go to an airport that's how
we're about to travel and so I'm like oh
my god can you [ __ ] come out and play
the guy with two cups of coffee again
like it's like 19 years later that be
amazing he's like a boar shooting
something with Julia on veep that that
day he's going there any other dag come
out I was like what we're shooting a
movie scene you could be drinking a
coffee there and he was like done and
done
Dave Mandel flew all the way to
Louisiana just to stand in the
background and drink coffee again
and he was like look nobody else is
gonna find it funny but me he's like but
I'll travel that far for a joke and [ __ ]
so you could see him in the trailer he's
in the shot in the [ __ ] trailer and
he sent me like a text the other day
going holy [ __ ] you've got precious
seconds in the trailer and I'm one of
them there he is on display but as
clerks cartoon could happen this year
and I don't mean that no like you know
and we could fly like it there's a
concrete chance that it could happen
this year Mint stamps - stay tuned
how are you my name is Camille hi and
you look great I got to hear you talk
last year I need to spoke about your
heart attack a lot of people that were
in the audience we're talking about how
inspiring it was we're also glad you're
doing really well I think I speak for
all the fans thank you I love being here
so that I'm happy about it - only person
they'd brave asking their question in
front of all these people it's really
intimidating
how many people how do you think we feel
I'm sure right you're more used to than
I am yes she does have a single
spotlight on her they're like we're
we're all lit up here she has its
pressures on that's something good
Wow so I wanted to ask if there are any
projects that you haven't gotten to do
that you that you really want to do I
don't I don't know like there's for
years we wanted to do clerks three and
we couldn't and so when I finished
Jane's saw Bob reboot like Jane saw Bob
reboot was me being able to play with
the characters I didn't get to play with
in clerks three we didn't get to make I
didn't get to make Mallrats to Jay and
Silent Bob we own so we could do
anything we want with them and stuff and
obviously we do so we got to make that
movie and at the end of it I felt like
oh [ __ ] that's a really nice bow on the
Buick universe really nice bow in my
career like this should be the movie you
[ __ ] go out on because it says it all
and [ __ ] like that now have the heart
attack and drop dead like you're ready
and [ __ ] so that's about how much I love
the movie it really don't say that
please god I was just I was kidding I
forgot you yeah thank you then remember
you said let's do our last one will be
Jay humps Bob I don't remember that at
all like if I was gonna enduro baby I
don't know if I'm gonna end but I feel
like this is gonna sound so [ __ ]
corny but it's gonna sound like a STONER
thought Jay and Silent Bob like took
took us very far took us out of New
Jersey and I wasn't necessarily trying
to get out I like New Jersey and stuff
and I really liked where we grew up but
life took us on a different adventure
and thankfully he's been around me all
this time so a little piece of home
we're always kind of near each other
instead Jay and Bob gave us so much that
this movie is kind of like us giving
back to Jay and Silent Bob like where
they wind up and this movie sounds
ridiculous to say but where they wind up
in this movie is a place where like they
they deserve to be from our my
perspective because they gave us so much
in return if you can understand that
[ __ ] the guys I know they're not real
and I know their characters that we play
in characters on a page but at the same
time without them like I don't we don't
go this far
the other two part of that equation are
Dante and Randal like those four boys
I built my entire career upon their
backs and they took me around the world
they were my passport to everything and
I was very happy with where we left
Dante and Randall and clerks too like I
was so happy that the moment in that
movies one of my favorite moments in any
movie not just when I made is when they
realize that they are in command to
their future that they could by quick
stop and reopen it themselves and [ __ ]
like that
that was me giving back to my characters
who had given me so much like they gave
me the world and I was like I can't
leave him stuck in the [ __ ]
convenience store like I got to deliver
him and I did and then delivered him
back to the [ __ ] convenience store
but at least they owned at this time and
[ __ ] so then when I wrote clerks three I
wrote it during a weirder darker time in
my life and it is kind of like the King
Lear of all our movies like it's really
depressing it's about death we're gonna
do a reading of it in New Jersey August
3rd and 4th or something like that or
fourth and fifth as a benefit for the
1st Avenue Playhouse in Atlantic islands
where we did auditions for clerks 25
years ago and [ __ ]
26 years ago at this point so we're
gonna read it out loud soon and stuff
and I love it it's one of my favorite
scripts but it's like dark and it's
bleak and it's not like what Dante and
Randall deserve so we're never gonna
make that version of clerks 3 but Dante
and Randall do deserve just a little
more than they got so I haven't said it
to anybody I didn't even said it to him
and [ __ ] like that
but I'm gonna write a different clerks
three and we're gonna make that [ __ ]
movie I promise
I owe those guys and there's one story
now that I'm kind of desperate to tell
with them Jay and Silent Bob will be
there of course we'll be in the
background we just had our moment in the
Sun with this movie and [ __ ] but Dante
and Randall are gonna have like one last
adventure and I'm gonna leave them in a
place where you know for all the cinema
history and when I die and [ __ ] I'll be
very happy where they are they gave me
so much I owned this last thing so
clerks three is gonna happen man I don't
know if it's next but it's gonna happen
[Applause]
all right over to you sir thank you have
an update on Howard the dock at all the
update on howard the duck i just saw
Jeff lobe on the IMD boat in terms of
the orders of the shows right now our
show goes last
first MODOK is happening then it's hit
monkey and then it's Dazzler and Tygra
and then it's Howard the Duck my partner
on that show is the brilliant Dave
Willis who created Aqua Teen Hunger
Force yes
he's he's the sensibility that you want
to go along with with Howard I'm there
believe me I'm all given my all but like
Howard Steve Gerber's Howard was like
genre-bending we need a genre bender to
come in and work on the show so Dave is
putting together a writers room that all
adds some stuff to as well some people
too and then we're gonna be moving
forward within the next two months I
think our writers room opens up and
stuff so we're like you know a year away
from the cartoon to be honest with you
but I'm sure it'll be good man Marvel
doesn't do anything bad thank you
there's another one we got a wrap now
all right this is the last one you're
the last one you're gonna close this out
man I'm pretty excited better be good
son I'll try all right no pressure no
price so this whole
so uh things makes me feel really
excited for your movie but also I feel a
little old right now because I actually
my first chemistry panel I was 17 in
2001 and I saw Jane Stanislav right back
you were at that panel panel yes my wife
well we were just talking about tonight
she she when she thinks of that panel
she's like that was the panel I got
crushed because remember we were giving
out tickets to the screening and we got
one you got one of the tickets we didn't
think that like people would rush the
[ __ ] stage it was scary for a minute
there she got pushed up against it and
stuff but you know we got the tickets
given away that was a fun screening like
I don't think if I rush yeah no I wasn't
blaming you man I was I wasn't like
honey here he is let's get him all right
he pushed your mother once it was
probably my best day at Comic Con
because I was seeing the row right
behind Jen and you know Harley when she
was like three years old yeah but that
was if that was 2001 yeah she was two
years old at that point yeah yeah and
later on that night saw your movie month
early actually saw you and talked to you
a little bit in the lobby and even gave
Jason some of mighties fries and it was
a really great moment for me yeah well
thanks for those Brown
her and I you mentioned cheese fries in
that movie so it felt like a mirror
within a mirror have ception so that
leads to the very important question is
there any mention of cheese fries in the
reboot Aegean science blog right back
there's gonna be we may have to go in
and remix the sound a little bit but
can't [ __ ] let you down now man
ladies and gentlemen if you had a good
time this evening I can't thank you
enough for being here but let me thank
the folks that are here give it up for
mr. Jason Mewes give it up for mr.
Harley Quinn Smith give it up for the
great Melissa Benoist
I've been Kevin Smith the movies called
Jay and Silent Bob reboot come see us on
the reboot roadshow ladies and gentlemen
I was scared to come out here I should
never be scared you guys have always got
my back I love you to death folks see
you next year everybody happy comic-con
all right give it up once again for me
Kevin Smith three boots Holly trap
[Applause]
hey man I'm Kevin Smith Casey Muse guess
what we made a sequel to Jay and Silent
Bob strike back and we imaginative Lee
called it Jay and Silent Bob repo
starring me that's right it stars me too
in the second role man you want to see
it we want to show it to you so we're
bringing it to you to your hometown you
can watch it with us and afterwards
we're gonna answer all your questions
that's right it's the Jay and Silent Bob
reboot Roadshow so come on out and join
us give us your money cuz we got to eat
this year yeah so does my kid man so
good tickets every boot row Joe calm see
you there
[Music]